everyone it's jennifer garner
hi drew i can't believe i'm not there
with you i just want to give you like a
big old squeeze
i remember the very first time i was in
a room with you i ran right over to you
in fact i think we have a picture of it
i mean literally i look like i'm meeting
my like
big crush in life and i was and i
i was so excited also because that was
you know
around let's see 2004 was definitely
charlie's angels era
for me and coming out of it and you were
doing alias
and it was so exciting i felt like
it was hard to establish yourself as a
woman who wasn't trying to be a man
if you were doing stuff that men did
exactly well you know the whole reason i
got so excited about investing myself in
stunts and doing them all and learning
to fight and being on wires was because
of charlie's angels
just because i was such an enormous fan
of what you guys did
and how you changed the game and i ended
up working with your same
stunt crew yucky some teleci and i
ended up working with those same guys on
a movie later and was just like tell me
everything they did how did they train
what was it like
you're my inspiration drew oh my gosh
you are my inspiration for so many
things
and the way you are protective with your
kids and trying to create
laws around you know kids protective
you know stuff with paparazzi you're
just
you've been such an activist how did you
become such a
good grounded realistic awesome activist
for kids
gosh so i started working for save the
children
um 12 years ago my daughter is 15
and having grown up in west virginia
surrounded by
rural generational poverty and having a
mom
who grew up super poor in oklahoma i
realized that i really was looking for
who was helping kids like my mom are
like the kids that i grew up with
i always say i grew up one generation
and one hauler
removed from poverty but i i s it
it touched me i saw it i saw the the
inequality
of opportunity and of just possibility
for kids that i grew up with and
and i saw what a miracle my mom was in
her own circumstance and what a hero she
is of her story and i just feel like
you need some help to become the hero of
your story if you have
less so i did get to work for save
really quietly for years i mean years
but then
eventually once social media became a
thing and we all
joined it um which i went into kicking
and screaming save the children said to
me
part of what you should be doing is
you know not just sharing these stories
in a room
but share them with the world i know
that i am genuinely trying to share my
experience because i think life is a
communal experience and we are
all equally in this you know time
together and that's exactly what i smell
from you
it's just so genuine and i'm not
watching it
yeah i feel the same about watching you
when you have
a tip about your kids or when you have
an idea i feel like oh man i feel like i
could try that because
you couldn't be i know we could sit down
right now and get
real in about three seconds about our
kids about our lives that's just
and what's the point otherwise what is
the point
of doing anything that isn't you know
coming from something which is a huge
part not i'm not trying to
you know switch topics but once upon a
farm
had to fit inside the circle of what i
already had going on in my life it
i couldn't start a business that was
something like
totally out of the blue it had to be
something that was all interconnected
because it just feels goofy
otherwise like that is the farm that my
mom grew up on where she
though you know the the little root
cellar where she and hers that's where
me as an 11 year old with a with a cow
named jennifer
and at a certain point it just made more
sense for it to be
under my care and so i had to i had to
buy it from my family but going back to
try to find the paperwork it was bought
on a handshake
and it's incredible it's just the most
special full circle
um gift to have in in my little family's
life that we have
our little farm has come to life and is
growing food for babies
does the control room have the picture
of me i just sent you guys
because i tried to like screen grab a
video i made while eating your once upon
a farm packet
i'm genuinely on an airplane just
guzzling
remember yes oh my god you don't even
know
it was it was such an incredible just
boost to all of us to have your support
for our little
plant-based you know we're just like
this little dicky dick oh but look
um this new blend kicks off
our save the children partnership so
we're um once upon a farm is starting to
this year
you know we're we're starting off with
this blend but it's going to expand next
year and we're helping kids
in america have access to just better
nutrition all in all ways
you're a really solid human being and
everything you take on in your life
the way you handle it i'm just like oh
my god the thing that you you
you talked about with your kids writing
a note
about like i want to grow up and what
was it i'd be a fun killer
this was legitimate this happened this
showed up on my desk when i grow up i
want to be a fun killing mom
just like you
[Laughter]
you know mom why can't i ever do what i
want to mom
that's my son i have to show those to my
daughters because they're just gonna
love those and that's the kind of stuff
that when you share it
it's charming and yet i'm like oh my
okay my kids would definitely write a
note like that too
and uh i've talked to elisa who i know
that you know
i love that you share elisa's wisdom
with the world
she is another level she's on the show
today
and not to put you on the spot but if
you ever want to do something with the
three of us
the three of us oh we wouldn't get
anything done but yeah for sure
yes that's perfect